one of the mantras that I've been
practicing is just saying remember like
this is the good time as I'm sure people
say to you all the time Mel like what's
the what are you working on what's the
big thing where you know what's the next
thing or whatever I get that question a
lot and
I don't
there isn't really a net is this isn't
driving towards something that I don't
already have like this is [ __ ]
awesome to be able to do this I want to
just be able to wake up every day and be
excited about it like nothing is static
there will come a day where I don't want
to do this anymore or this won't be
happening or you know some intervening
event could occur that derails me who
knows what's going to happen but right
now like it's great you know and I'm
having fun and I can provide for my
family and I can employ people who seem
to enjoy working here like what is
better than that to be excited about
what you get to do every day and to
share it with people that enjoy it and
are nourished by it like it's [ __ ]
awesome